[Music]
I love granola for a month I carried a
Tupperware of it in my purse 100 calorie
I'm going to try to put a hundred
calories of granola on this plate okay
run Ola I feel like it's very light on
the calories 54 grams yeah that's my
final answer
I can't believe this is 100 calories
that is so sad
these are definitely baked chips these
are very health conscious chips I think
this is about a hundred calories oh dear
the other penalty one two three four
five six seven there's probably 15
fifteen chips here Wow
if you were to have regular potato chips
I assume it would probably be like four
chips I think life gets boring as you
get old so people need mustard to make
like hotdogs interesting I feel like a
detective
I'm the calorie detective
that's it it sounds good I would eat
this
Jesus 100 calories Wow
so that's fascinating Donna bustard and
that's 100 calories what is it mustard
all right here we go 100 calories of
this yeah let's go with that
that's 100 calories ha ha ha
knowledge America I don't like that this
is at every Italian restaurant and
people douse their bread in it I use
like at least like four times this
amount that's why every time you leave
an Italian restaurant you're sleeping
all right it's a strawberries who does
have a lot of sugar I think that's about
100 calories
maybe that amount I think that ah oh my
god that makes me really happy this is
just so heartwarming that this hearty
bowl of strawberries is only 100
calories these are the same amount of
calories which is a kind of the same
very different volume that's
unbelievable Wow I think that we're
poorly educated about how much calories
are in our food we need smaller portions
in our chips we get smaller portions and
everything except mustard America needs
more mustard America needs smaller
portions and more mustard did you go
through breakup and you like need
distress eat it just like just take two
strawberries and mustard that's all good
[Music]